do you remember the 80s and the 90s we
had female action heroes back then Sarah
Connor and the Terminator Lola and Ron
Lola Run and Ellen Ripley in the alien
movies Ellen Ripley had a shaved head
used the flamethrower massacred aliens
and saved the human race did we think it
was weird that a woman was doing this no
we just accepted that she was a lesbian
and got on with our lives if you want
something done properly get a man to do
it but if you're tired of nagging your
man to do it get agenda non-conforming
female and the main villain in the alien
movies was a female alien which is how
you knew she was properly evil as any
nightclub bouncer will tell you the
worst fights are the ones between two
women that's why that movie is a classic
I'm just surprised the Queen alien
didn't try and stab Ripley with a
stiletto whilst her mates in the
background scream Tanya don't do it's
not worth it all those movies had a
positive thing to say about men and
women
have you ever been mistaken for a man no
have you
it is too bad
but now relations between the two Sexes
have gone down the toilet if you believe
the movies anyway the Barbie film
demonstrates this perfectly it explains
why Society without men is far better
and more harmonious this obviously is a
load of bollocks as anyone who's worked
with women will tell you they're all
three pina coladas away from tearing
each other's hair out I love women but
if they're all so loving then why is it
on a night out the fat one always ends
up crying there was only one token fat
girl in the Barbie movie because
Barbie's audience is white women and gay
men they save the fat ladies for the
hip-hop videos Barbie really was
unrealistic trash it's set in Venice
Beach and I didn't see one crackhead
taking a dump on the street whilst
mainlining fentanyl into his nut sack
where was the homeless psychopath
harassing you for money where were the
needles this is way more unrealistic
than a plastic doll coming to life and
it sets kids up with fake expectations
of what La is really like Hollywood has
not just drunk the Kool-Aid it's guzzled
from the barrel then taking the dregs
and made suppositories so it can be
screwed from both ends Michael Sheen
recently said that only Welsh actors
should play Welsh characters how many
Welsh characters can you name they've
been about three interesting people to
come from Wales in their entire history
and one of them is a dragon have we now
come to the point where only dragons can
play dragons are dragons now part of an
oppressed minority will we see the rise
of dlm comedian David bediel said that
Robert Oppenheimer should have been
played by a Jew I think for maximum
authenticity he should have been played
by someone who's autistic every
physicist in the history of the planet
is autistic unless the actor is a
mathematical genius with appalling
social skills and an inability to make
eye contact
I ain't interested he needs to be so
autistic that the only way he can
communicate is through Morse code and if
he isn't then this is another disgusting
example of neurodivergent washing Peter
Dinklage has taken the opposite tack
he's arguing that actors with dwarfism
should not be cast as dwarfs in Snow
White and the Seven Dwarfs so an actor
with dwarfism is depriving other actors
with dwarfism of well-paid Hollywood
roles talk about pulling up the tiny
little step ladder now there's just one
dwarf in the Seven Dwarfs isn't this
just tokenism will we call it Snow White
six blokes and a dwarf because that
sounds less like a kids movie and more
like a porn movie Snow White is played
by an actor of Latin Heritage now I am a
massive fan of the Dusky Maiden my
dating history looks like a Hollywood
Casting agent's wet dream all brown
women and no dwarfs but shouldn't Snow
White be
Snow White is it really an authentic
choice to have a lady who looks like she
can dance and mean salsa a temper that
could destabilize entire nations and
hairier than Osama Bin Laden these are
all qualities that I find highly
desirable in a woman but maybe not for
the character of Snow White however
Rachel zedner is half Colombian so maybe
snow white refers to that country's
greatest export who wouldn't want to see
Snow White meets narcos maybe Prince
Charming is in the CIA and will rescue
her from Pablo Escobar the actress who
plays Snow White has come under Fire for
this interview
I just mean that it's no longer 1937 and
we absolutely wrote a snow white that is
not going to be saved by the prince
she's not gonna be safe with the prince
and she's not going to be dreaming about
true love she's dreaming about becoming
the leader she knows she can be and the
leader that her late father told her
that she could be if she was Fearless
Fair Brave and true and so it's just a
really incredible story for I think
young people everywhere to see
themselves in I have sympathy for her
she's 22 years old what 22 year old
doesn't have dementedly liberal opinions
that's what you should be like at 22.
then you realize that all polyamory left
you with is badly dyed hair some
terrible sexual experiences and
chlamydia the worst people in life are
those who are conservative when they're
barely adults go have some fun instead
of living your life like a Ben Shapiro
tribute act she also branded Prince
Charming a creep if someone calls
himself Charming it's probably because
they've got something to hide it's like
when a used car salesman calls himself
honest dive if you call yourself
something it's highly likely you're not
that thing and he did kiss her when she
was asleep I'm just surprised that his
name wasn't discovered on the flight log
for Epstein's Island well at the very
least describe himself as a male
feminist instead of dogpiling her maybe
we should allow her to grow up and do
what all liberal women do when they
mature marry a conservative because
there's nothing liberal women love more
than hearing the words no backed up with
facts and logic they love a little bit
of Ben Shapiro from a man who can pay
his own way and grow a proper beard
which is the main reason why I'm not a
conservative
foreign
[Music]